so yeah the Wilson document or the Eric
Davis memo however you want to refer to
it was a series of notes recorded by
Eric Davis who's a physicist with an
absolute unbelievable memory
um and I've talked to that guy the
details that are in his brain uh
are phenomenal so it's conceivable that
he could remember such a meeting so he
had a meeting with a man named Admiral
Tom Wilson
uh back in the 1990s again I just don't
remember the exact year but
uh and it was in a car and then after
the meeting was over he made these notes
about what would happen in that meeting
and it's in that meeting
um Avril Admiral Wilson described how he
had tried to get access to some of these
special he was I think he was a joy
Chiefs of Staff at the time again if I
had known we were going to talk about
this I would have refreshed my memory
before I came on but um he was a very
high level and he believed that he
should if there were such a program
which was looking into crashed objects
of you know non-human origin that he
would know so he went banging on doors
trying to find the location of these
programs
and he was telling Eric Davis at this
meeting that he had found one
and they acknowledged that they had a
crashed object not made by human hands
was the way they described it these
people in this program but they were not
going to allow for him access he was not
on the bigot list of people who had
access and they basically told him to go
away and then he was
told to keep his mouth shut by people
about it and not to pursue this any
further
um and that's basically what I mean I
encourage it's fascinating to read this
memo you have to go on and read it um
and so
uh Wilson has denied that the meeting
ever happened
and Eric cannot comment on it so he
doesn't say one way or the other exactly
yeah he's not going to comment on it
um I my my colleague Ralph Blumenthal
and I tried to dig into this and it's
it's very hard to get any definitive
on the record sources that could verify
anything around that memo even though
there's a lot of names in there and
stuff like that it's it's just
impossible to I mean there's been some
great research done on it I'm not the
one who's done it
by various people in the UFO research
world have done fantastic documents and
long reports on this
um which I'm trying trouble naming right
now but um
there's a lot of information out there
about it yeah and do you take Eric
Davis's no comment as an admission of
its veracity because if it was false he
would just say no it's false does he
always say no comment no matter what
well you'd have to look and again there
are documents out there that have have
everything Eric has ever said about this
written down you know so you can look
and decide for yourself I personally
know him I believe he's an honest
individual he would not make I don't
believe personally he would make this up
so I don't believe he did make it up and
I know he has an extraordinary memory
and
you know I'll leave it at that